hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown president
Trump's 2020 campaign manager Brad parse
kale catches up with host Dave Anthony
about why he feels the impeachment fight
will help the commander-in-chief's
re-election effort
he'll also weigh in on the Democratic
presidential candidates and who he feels
pose the greatest and the least threat
to the president the Wuhan corona virus
outbreak has some on edge director of
the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases dr. Anthony Fauci
joins host Lisa Brady to talk about the
deadly illness and the concerns
surrounding it Plus commentary by Fox
News senior judicial analyst Judge
Andrew Napolitano the Fox News rundown
is a Daily News podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important to
you you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player by going to FoxNews
podcast.com i'm harris faulkner
I'm Greg Gutfeld I'm Janice Dean and
this is the Fox News rundown
Friday January 24th 2020 I'm Dave
Anthony the impeachment trial continues
today
but the president's campaign manager
tells us it's only helping their effort
to reelect him the president's able were
able to go out and talk about policies
and things while all of them all they
talk about is you know Trump bad get him
out
and Lisa Brady it's a virus that keeps
reinventing itself finding new ways to
jump from animals to humans and leaving
health officials on high alert as they
try to contain the latest outbreak it
really is quite important for us to
seriously consider which we are to try
and develop what we call a universal
vaccine that we've covered the whole
loop of these koala viruses
I'm Judge Andrew Napolitano and I've got
the final word on the Fox News rundown
for a third day in a row the seven House
Democrats prosecuting President Trump
will be making the case for senators to
vote him out for abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress over holding up
military aid to Ukraine while demanding
an investigation into Joe Biden and son
no president has ever used his office to
compel a foreign nation to help him
cheat in our elections Congressman Jerry
Nadler during the trial on Thursday he
argues that even if we disapprove of his
misconduct we cannot remove him for it
frankly that argument is itself
terrifying starting Saturday the Trump
legal team will also get up to 24 hours
to present a defense but with a
Republican majority in the Senate and 67
votes needed to convict it is widely
expected the president will be acquitted
I can tell you from the campaign side
the impeachment said nothing but help us
hell up oh yeah oh yeah fundraising
numbers Brad Farr scale is the Trump
2020 campaign manager you know Americans
aren't dumb they see this for what it is
and you know our fundraising numbers
skyrocketed and have stayed up since it
started our recent voter scores and our
other kind of things we use in data
science have all showed up people are
sending me polls you know everything
there's not a metric I have right now
that's down from this polls have shown
over this process at times even there
was a Fox News poll that 50% or so of
Americans thought the president should
be impeached and removed from office
look I think it is a very partisan you
know you have a you have a very strong
base on both sides right now that is
very you know I feel like it's a little
bit like world war one there just
trenched right not moving anywhere and I
think when you ask them and the way they
sample those and do stuff you can you
can flip back from 40 to 50 s and things
like that look not much has changed in
that partisanship and what the only
thing that's changed now as the
president has really secured up the
Republican base compared to 2016 so
we're in a better position and and what
they've done and kind of dismissing
independents and a lot of this because
indepence are very much about getting
things done the present
table and we're able to go and talk
about policies and things while all of
them all they talk about is you know
trump bad get him out you know and so
they just that's all they do they it's
like Tarzan you know and that's all they
say and that gives us a great window to
talk to the independence what number
would you say is the independent in this
whole thing you said forty maybe people
talk about forty on each side I think I
think the Trump base strong like
entrenches pie somewhere between 43 and
44 percent all right so you know lately
voter lights what you get you're gonna
get that well the other thing
automatically here's the thing is people
play with a lot of things so you got
likely voters registered voters adults I
mean they do all kinds of stuff there's
you know doing a very good likely voter
poll is very expensive you don't see a
lot of those you know they can cost a
really good one across the United States
to really know what's happen to a
million to two million dollars when when
you're talking about the swing states
obviously the president won some huge
ones with Wisconsin Michigan Sylvania
Michigan right those were they carried
him to the to the presidency where are
you would you like what you just said
though they used to be Ohio and Florida
or the swing states now we talk about it
now now we've changed the map now Ohio
was pretty easy well yeah why was it
nice win I mean as far as everyone now
back in 16 I used to do these radio
shows right towards the end as being
digital director and kind of being
Jarrod's deputy and people would like oh
you know we gotta win Ohio for those the
swing states now it's like oh now you
have to win Michigan it's like we've
expanded the map and now we're actually
talking and people and even the
Democrats will start to say New
Hampshire New Mexico Nevada
you know these states are are coming up
Minnesota
smaller numbers of electoral votes
Mexico New Hampshire of course yeah but
III think that Minnesota is a good one
the VAT is a good one I mean the so
doesn't play you really believe yeah I
in play yes I think you've depending on
who their candidate is Minnesota has a
changing demographics over the years
they do and I think Minnesota is one of
those states like Wisconsin I think it's
a sleeper for 2016 I definitely think
New Hampshire and New Mexico or
significantly play no way I went to
Clinton very very tiny
more and then you actually had a very
hot race there was very strange where
you had a senator that was running kind
of against the president who lost New
York I see that this time
[Music]
that was a different atmosphere in New
Hampshire - you had a very you know you
know contested primary you know New
Hampshire always plays a big part in
that it makes it different compared to a
reelect I also think the the president
is over performing with every single
metric from 2016 olesja voters and so
that brings states in the southwest
changes significantly you know that
seems counterintuitive because the
president has been under attack for
years with his border policy and and is
from a whole bunch of white media yeah
well I'm just saying that they they made
it seem like he didn't remember he
didn't want brown people coming here
yeah that's completely just another one
of their their false narratives they
they want to they attack him identity
politics because they can't attack him
on policy and so I mean he's been called
a white supremacist racist possibly a
vulgar comet that is disgusting and
nothing that this president stands for
the president has done more for
minorities and for economic benefits
than any president in recent history
that I ever remember and I go back to
the Reagan years the economy is always
considered the big issue for a
presidential incumbent as they say job
hits job stupid right right well see the
thing is people thought for a while in
2019 that the economy because of the
tariffs was going to go into the tank or
slow down maybe you have a recession and
the thought is if we went in a recession
that would be really hard for the
president reelected it'd be really great
to just do a whole podcast of all the
things they said we're gonna happen it
didn't happen and I had to answer
questions for because the president
brought in record amount of number of
money from China it cause what we had
were a close to I but I wouldn't be
shocked if for the next 10 days we're at
Dow 30 thousand right wouldn't be
unusual to be there is China paying the
tariffs right I mean I think there was a
lot of arguments that I heard at the
White House from different experts
saying how China had to you know like
Hut you know not lowering the prices and
really have to do it on the backside
because raising the prices would have
done things they were already playing
with their gets off I'm not gonna be an
expert at at White House policies but
I'll tell you it had we did not see the
negative impacts against the economy job
you know record low unemployment record
increases in median wage income record
401k growth record stock market
I'm almost every metric on the economy's
doing great the first contest is a week
from Monday the Iowa caucuses and recent
polls have had either Bernie Sanders or
Joe Biden leading but Elizabeth Warren
as a new campaign ad that President
Trump fears her as the Democratic
nominee the most he's done everything he
can for the wealthy and well-connected
I'm Elizabeth Warren and I approve this
message because I'm going to beat him
and be a president who works for you
Brad Parr scales response yes we fear
her greatly I hope she wins so do you
really hope she wins do you know I would
love nobody more than Elizabeth really
that's yeah I would I mean if you're
gonna give me my Christmas present I
just get to choose one yeah I mean
there's a couple hours I choose were way
down the list but let's talk about a
realistic candidate Elizabeth Warren
Elizabeth Warren what is it that you
think is so beatable about her then that
we don't have enough podcast for that
but well take a couple that honest is a
is a is a it it would be a great
candidate for the president from her
contrasting views to how she see things
she is she's just for most of Middle
America not likable she looks like good
I mean I the way I would explain her is
you know like a 8th grade school teacher
that a vice principal that just yells at
you all day you know what I mean or your
college professor that just says you
were dumb I just think that she's out of
touch with what most of our kids I grew
up in eastern Kansas I grew up with a
you know in a working-class town I you
know I spent most of my time in places
that are not on the east and west coast
and she's not gonna she's just not gonna
connect there you know not the way
Bernie or Biden has the possibility to
Biden himself has also said that the
president's scared to death
they're all saying they're scared look
they all have the exact same talking
points because the number one thing I
think on their side for getting votes is
to say the president doesn't want to run
against me
well Biden says he's the one he's the
guy that the president can't be he is
definitely the
yeah I don't I think Biden's inability
to kind of you know keep his his points
across and really run a successful camp
I don't know if he can raise the money
either I'm curious to see what his
interviewer or uh you know cash-on-cash
my hand number is when it comes out
later this month another Democrat in the
race Michael Bloomberg has risen in some
national polls lately and his campaign
manager Kevin cheeki told Fox and
Friends Thursday Elizabeth Warren better
watch out I think she's nervous that
Mike Bloomberg is catching up on her
Mike is now in fourth place in this race
and will probably pass her and be in
third place he's a two or three very
encouraging poll no question about it
Bloomberg has said he's spending all his
money to get rid of Trump and could
spend up to a billion dollars to help
the Democratic nominee even if it is in
him a first of all I worry about mayor
Mayor Bloomberg once he gets past mayor
beat Pete and Pocahontas so in the polls
he's not there yet all right when it
comes to the soft money I think there's
gonna be there's always billions of
dollars literally billions of dollars
soft money flying in one thing we've
learned from special elections and other
things is soft money when it doesn't
have a candidate you know connected
behind it it just doesn't have the same
kind of static as as it does I mean last
time
we got a couple billion dollars during
our total budget was 260 million and if
you look at the effectiveness of our
hard dollars compared to that it's
almost 20 to 1 a soft dollar so he'd
have to spend billions I'm not worried
about that I think the Bloomberg's
message is wrong I don't think I don't
think he's connecting I think he's to
New York and maybe in New Yorkers will
understand it but you know I'm not
worried about the New York in the
California vote but what if in October
he's not the nominee yet he spends and
an all over the TV for a month always
see our anti Trump ads that he was all
we had last time well there's only so
much TV yet like last time every ad was
a negative Trump ad so look I look I
don't know if just spending a billion
dollars on TVs it changes anything
anymore there's there's digital efforts
there's understanding the data the
Democrat Party doesn't understand the
voter base the way the Republican Party
does we've spent a decade now at the
data trust and building up a voter file
and understanding and and metrics that
are second to none and and they have no
centralized database still I think the
debates will matter I think what the
president says will matter I think where
the country is going into the election
matters and I think it's a very
it's a very intimate thing to do to go
into the voting booth and a lot of
people say one thing when they get in
that voting booth they vote about their
future and their children's future I
think the president will prevail again
our suburban women offended by President
Trump as I hear in the media that it's
gonna be tougher for the women who voted
for him last time to do it this time in
the suburbs look i-i've actually went
back and researched this greatly lots of
the suburban women changes to the
Republican Party actually predate the
president go back into midterms actually
before him a lot of people like oh my
god look at the suburban women decline
in the 2018 race right everybody said
that significantly did you know the 2018
suburban women vote matches the 2014
suburban women vote for Republicans
matches identical women overall across
America according to our focus groups
and polling don't like politicians it's
not they don't like Republicans they
don't like the Democrats either okay
they are turned off by what's happening
in America with our partisan atmosphere
so what do you do to turn them to trump
now that's the thing remember when they
go in the voting booth they're voting
for the policies of a president what
they think said we better for this
country and I think that the president's
policies with that group compared to any
one of the candidates in their group in
every test we've done so far the
president goes from goes to almost 70 80
percent of taking that vote and the
reason why is these big government
socialist programs these you know the
different things they want to do with
free health care for illegal immigrants
the gun control issues all these things
the women don't agree with the policies
and when they come down to it they're
smart they know the policies and they
and they vote for the candidate that's
gonna make their life better and keep
their kids safe and I think that and
they might walk right out again and push
that button and walk right out and say
you know what I still don't prove
everything he does but he's the best
candidate for my future my family and
for us
Brad bar scale campaign manager for
president Trump 2020 thanks so much for
joining us it was great it was fun thank
you I appreciate it thanks a lot right
this is Judge Napolitano with your Fox
News commentary
coming up the outbreak of a new type of
corona virus that appears to have
started in China has been spreading
quickly in Asia killing more than 20
people and sickening hundreds the first
u.s. case confirmed in Washington State
though on Thursday the World Health
Organization decided it's too soon to
declare a global public health emergency
it's may yet become one
waho director-general dr. Ted Drewes
Cabrillo says says it is an emergency in
China where some cities have essentially
been shut down like a giant quarantine
for millions of people they've also
canceled major public events for the
Lunar New Year in Beijing in the u.s.
airport screenings of international
passengers especially related to central
China have been expanded White House
spokesman Hogan Gidley
we are monitoring the situation in
real-time the president has been briefed
and remains consistently vigilant in
making sure that this doesn't spread
throughout our country other possible
cases were being monitored Thursday in
California and Texas also involving
travelers symptoms of what's being
called the novel coronavirus can include
fever cough and shortness of breath
similar to other respiratory infections
which can include other types of corona
virus corona viruses or viruses that
we've had a lot of experience with dr.
Anthony Fauci is head of the National
Institute of Allergy and Infectious
Disease at the National Institutes of
Health their viruses that occur in
animals and humans and there are four
corona viruses that account for about Oh
10 to 25% of all of the common colds and
mild upper respiratory infections that
we get every winter in our community
however in 2002 a corona virus from the
big family of corona viruses that jumped
species from an animal reservoir and
infected humans in China and that is the
now-famous SARS virus severe acute
respiratory syndrome
led to a global pandemic in 2002 2003
with 8,000 cases in 775 yes
he says SARS was contained and stopped
with classic public health measures
identification isolation and quarantine
but a decade later in 2012 another
coronavirus jump species from animal to
human known as Middle East respiratory
syndrome that infected over 2000 people
killing about 800 the disease is serious
at 10 percent mortality with SARS and
about a 30% or so mortality with mares
so the bottom line it's a virus who
historically had better relatively
benign virus but when an animal version
of a jump species that can cause serious
respiratory disease particularly among
elderly individuals and those who have
underlying conditions that was part of
my next question because when there's an
outbreak of anything it tends to scare
people but how dangerous is this
particular virus for the population at
large or is it like the flu where it's
only really dangerous depending on your
age and your health well you know we
don't know for sure I think it's too
early this is an evolving situation but
with most respiratory illnesses that
have a degree of seriousness to it it
tends almost invariably to be much more
serious in people who already have
either an underlying condition chronic
lung disease heart disease diabetes but
also the elderly in that the elderlies
immune system isn't as fit in many
respects as that same person when they
were in their 20s or 30s so somebody was
85 years old generally has weaknesses in
their ability to make a good immune
response and that's the reason why when
you have diseases like this it tends to
disproportionately have a more severe
impact on the elderly and/or people who
have underlying disease it seems like
we're already working through some of
the same steps that were used to combat
SARS I didn't
Haitian isolation I know China has
started locking down some cities now
trying to really help contain the spread
by limiting people's movements how
effective do you think you know that
might be well certainly what we're doing
here in the United States is we're doing
what's called entry screening of flights
that either directly or indirectly come
from that region that's sitting that
area by testing people for temperature
and questioning them about symptoms
invariably we predicted that we would
see a case or more in the United States
and in fact just a couple of days ago a
young man from Seattle visited Wuhan and
then came back develop symptoms and
luckily you know the idea about getting
people aware awareness is an important
part of prevention and response the CDC
has been putting out notices to people
to make sure when someone presents with
a respiratory illness to ask them the
simple question have you been traveling
to the new Han area of China
this individual was alert enough to go
to a clinic and say I have a fever and I
have the respiratory problem and by the
way I was in Wuhan just literally a few
days ago that person was isolated and is
now in isolation and doing very well so
you can prevent by preventing people who
come in from going freely in society and
isolating them or when people are sick
to make sure that properly careful and
you do contact tracing those are the
things that actually put the lid on SARS
because SARS came and went due to very
good classical low tech public health
measures I know that the CDC already
announced that they had come up with a
test to quickly identify whether someone
has the virus but going forward you've
said that at NIH there is a vaccine in
the works but I guess that's not going
to be a fast process and ever is right
is a multi-step process
jumped on this pretty quickly we have
what's called a vaccine platform that
we've been working on for a while in
collaboration with industry and what
we've done we've started under the
development of a vaccine
unlike years ago and it would take years
to finally get it into a human we
anticipate we will have a Phase one
safety trial with this candidate within
the next three months now be careful
because that doesn't mean a vaccine is
going to be widely available to the
public in three months that means we
will at least have taken the first
important step to determine if the
product is safe and does it induce the
kind of response that you would hope
would be protected once you do that
depending upon how this outbreak evolves
we would need to further develop it or
just keep it in the can as it were
waiting and making sure if this doesn't
blow up into something but the important
thing is to take that first step which
we already have done it sounds like it
would be great to be able to come up
with a vaccine that would fight sort of
the the the basic corona virus that
keeps changing in to these horrible
things and then being transmitted to
human you know as it these steps that
happen with with SARS and with mares I
mean is there any way to head it off at
the pass you know we talked about
Universal vaccines vaccines that are
good against the whole class of family
of viruses that's not an easy thing to
do but given what we have seen now over
the last 18 years with SARS and then
mares and now this new novel coronavirus
it really is quite important for us to
seriously consider which we are to try
and develop what we call a universal
vaccine that would cover the whole group
of these corona viruses again I have to
tell you right off the bat that won't be
easy
but it certainly is worth seriously
considering going in that direction what
is your advice for now to anyone in the
u.s. worried about this virus
well I don't think that the people in
the United States right now should be
worried about it nor should they be
frightened by it I think health
officials like myself and my agency the
CDC Department of Homeland Security need
to make sure we're properly prepared
when a case comes into this country
which one already has to respond
appropriately to prevent spread but I
wouldn't want to see the American people
be frightened by this because we are
prepared for it it is an evolving
situation you can be taking something
very seriously the way we are without
necessarily being very afraid or anxious
about it so that's why my advice would
be is right now there's really no
coronavirus that's deadly out there for
the American public we have that one
case which is being well taken care of
but follow what's going on and when
there will be public health
announcements pay attention to them and
obviously wash your hands well yeah but
that eat that goes well beyond these
coronaviruses I think right now in the
middle still of a flu season we should
be washing our hands frequently avoiding
crowded places where people are sneezing
and coughing and things like that we
should be doing that even if there was
no corona virus outbreak dr. Anthony
Fauci
head of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Disease at the
National Institutes of Health thank you
very much sir for your time
[Music]
America is a special place every four
years we do something most people across
the globe only dream of democracy 2020
it's in your hands
Fox News America is watching and now
some good news with Tonya J powers
rocker Jon Bon Jovi is giving back to
his home state
he's opened 1/3 Jon Bon Jovi Soul
Kitchen which is a non-profit pay what
you can style restaurants this time it's
located on the Rutgers University campus
and it serves both paying and indeed
customers here's how it works it
encourages students and faculty who can
afford it to make a minimum donation of
$12 they can also pay it forward by
swiping an extra meal for non paying
diners gourmet dining President Michael
friend Jill OH says the company
approached John Bongiovi and his wife
Dorothea about it about a year ago after
seeing dozens of students lined up at a
campus food pantry one of three students
in the country's food insecure thinking
about that one out of three college
students is food insecure Dorothea
explains how it works
students in need who are unable to play
unable to pay contribute by volunteering
all guests enjoy a delicious
three-course dining experience giving a
roadmap to colleges and universities
across the country
Tanya J powers Fox News
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
Judge Andrew Napolitano what's on your
mind
I don't blame President Trump for his
angst and bitterness over his
impeachment by the House of
Representatives in his own mind he has
done quote nothing wrong and has not
acted outside the constitutional powers
vested in him and so his impeachment
should not have come to pass
hence his public denunciations of his
Senate trial as a charade a joke and a
hoax his trial is not a charade or a
joke or a hoax it is deadly serious
business based on well-established
constitutional norms the House of
Representatives in proceedings in which
the president chose not to participate
impeach the president Trump for abuse of
power and for contempt of Congress but
did he act criminally and is it
constitutionally necessary for the house
to point to a specific federal criminal
statute a crime committed by the
president in order to impeach him and
trigger a Senate trial here's the
backstory the Constitution prescribes
the basis for impeachment as quote
treason bribery or other high crimes and
misdemeanors
however this use of the word crimes does
not refer to violations of federal
criminal statutes it refers to
presidential behavior that is so
destructive of the constitutional order
that it is the moral equivalent of crime
so give you a couple of examples that
others have used as well if the
president moved to Russia and ran the
executive branch of the American federal
government from there or if he announced
that Roman Catholics were unfit for
federal office and he wouldn't nominate
any he would not have committed any
crimes yet surely these acts would be
impeach Abul because when done by the
president they are the moral equivalent
of crimes and they are so far removed
from constitutional norms as to be
impeachable in Trump's case though the
House of Representatives chose
delicately not to accuse the president
of specific crimes there is enough
evidence here to do so federal election
laws for example
prescribed as criminal the mere
solicitation asking for help for a
political campaign from a foreign
national or a foreign government there's
no dispute that Trump did this in fact
the case for this is stronger now than
it was when the House impeached him last
year since then more evidence which
President Trump tried to suppress has
come to light this behavior implicates
two other crimes one is bribery you have
a crime is contempt of Congress when the
House Select Committee on Intelligence
sought the emails that were eventually
unearthed by the press and then saw a
testimony from their authors Trump
thumbed his nose at the house instead of
complying with valid lawful House
subpoenas or challenging them in court
Trump's folks threw them in a drawer now
where does all this leave us at the
outset of Trump's Senate trial it leaves
us with valid lawful constitutional
arguments for Trump's impeachment that
he ought to take seriously that is
unless he knows he will be acquitted
because some Republican senators have
told him so I don't know if that
happened but if it did whoever may have
whispered that into the presidential ear
is unworthy of sitting as a juror and
has already violated his or her oath of
quote impartial justice and fidelity to
the Constitution and the law back to our
initial question what is required for
removal of the president a demonstration
of presidential commission of high
crimes and misdemeanors of which in
Donald Trump's case the evidence is
ample and uncontradicted Judge Andrew
Napolitano senior judicial analyst Fox
News
you have been listening to the FoxNews
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
the Fox News radios power Li newscast at
FoxNews podcasts dot-com and for
up-to-the-minute news visit Fox news.com
download fox news channels the five
podcast for free five of your favorite
fox news personalities discuss current
issues in a roundtable discussion get it
now on Apple podcasts Google Play in Fox
News